MODERATOR: Thank you
all for joining us
in the privilege of
being present today
to celebrate this wonderful
occasion in the life
of science, and of
MIT, and certainly
of our friend and
colleague Bob Horvitz.
There is no event that more
symbolizes and reminds us
of why we are all here than
when one of our colleagues
wins the highest possible
accolade for the science
that he or she has done.
The things that we
do at MIT, the things
that people, especially like
Bob, do in basic research,
in my view, is at
the absolute highest
level of human accomplishment.
And it is truly a privilege
to count Bob among our friends
and colleagues, and to
recognize how he has advanced
the state of human knowledge.
And how that knowledge
ultimately will improve health
for humankind.
So thank you all for being here.
And I would like now to ask
our colleague, Phil Sharpe,
to introduce Bob.
Phil.
SHARPE: It's a great
honor to be asked
to introduce Robert Horvitz.
And I want to begin
by congratulating
Bob for his outstanding
research and work here
at MIT as a colleague.
Bob's research,
as you will hear,
is fundamental to
all life processes.
Fundamental to how a
multicellular organism
is formed, fundamental to how
our brain is formed and works,
and fundamental to
the processes related
to disease such as cancer.
And therefore, as you would
expect, Bob has many homes.
He is a professor in the
Department of Biology,
he is an investigator in the
McGovern Institute for Brain
Research, and he is a member of
the Center for Cancer Research
here at MIT.
Beyond the borders of MIT,
Bob has also other homes.
He is a investigator in
the Howard Hughes Medical
Institute, and has been
supported by Howard Hughes
for many years.
And from the day he
came to MIT, almost,
he has been supported by the
National Institute of Health.
So Bob has many
friends and many homes.
Now, it has been
said that the best
predictor of whether you're
going to receive a Nobel Prize,
statistically, is having
your office within 50 yards
of another Nobel Prize winner.
In Bob's case, you want to
interpret that as mentors.
Now Bob was an
undergrad at MIT, where
he majored in mathematics
and economics,
and his advisor here was Bob
Solow, who, if you don't know,
has a Nobel in economics.
He went to Harvard,
and his advisor
at Harvard, where he
got his PhD in biology
was Jim Watson
and Wally Gilbert.
And that's three for three.
And then he went to
Cambridge to do a post-doc.
And there, things were
getting a little slow for him
in keeping this perfect record.
And his mentor at Cambridge
was Sidney Brenner
and John Sulston.
Sidney was his
post-doctoral mentor,
John is who he worked with, and
they share this honor with him
this year.
And that makes it
5 for five for Bob.
So if he wants to be a post-doc
in somebody's lab around here,
I'm sure others
would accept him.
Bob has been at MIT for many
years, since I think '76,
or something like that.
He not only has done
outstanding research,
but he has been a
wonderful colleague.
He teaches.
He teaches remarkably
well, as you will learn,
and enthusiastically.
And he has trained
some of the best
scientists this country has.
Every major university
in this country
has someone who
has been trained,
either as a graduate student
or a post-doctoral fellow,
in Bob Horvitz's lab.
He is the professional constant.
So it's a great pleasure
to introduce Bob today.
Let's all give him
around of applause.
HORVITZ: Thank you, Chuck and
Phil, for the introduction.
And thank all of you
[LAUGHING] including my wife
Martha, for coming here today.
This is a very
exciting time for me
and I can think of nothing
better than to share
this time with my MIT friends.
And I'd like to start with a few
specific statements of thanks
to these friends.
First and foremost, to my lab.
I thank the students
and postdocs
who have been members
of our research group,
because, as I'm sure most
people in this audience know,
it's really their
efforts, their insights,
and their accomplishments,
that have been recognized.
I thank my colleagues in
the Department of Biology.
These colleagues have provided
a spectacularly supportive
environment, and have
fostered my growth
as an independent scientist.
And their help,
their friendship,
remains a major force behind
my scientific efforts.
I particularly thank Boris
Magasanik, who hired me.
And also my other ex-
and current department
heads, Jean Brown, Morie Fox,
Richard Hines, Phil Sharpe,
and Bob Sour, for their
support over many years.
I thank Bob Sour
and Graham Walker,
with whom I grew up at MIT.
We entered as faculty members
at very much the same time.
And I thank Salva Luria and
David Baltimore, both of whom
made me think about
science, but also made
me think beyond science, to the
responsibilities of a scientist
in the country and the world.
Now Phil, when I first
came to MIT, it was 1964.
I'm kind of homegrown.
I came in 1964 as a freshman.
At that time, Paul Gray
was a 32-year-old associate
professor, and if
I recall correctly,
he was then, or soon thereafter,
chair of the freshman
advisory council.
The associate dean of
students was Fred Facet.
And I remember Fred very
distinctly from day one,
because as a freshman, I
sat in Kresge auditorium
as he addressed us.
And what he said was, look to
your left, look to your right.
One of you won't be here
when graduation time comes.
Times have changed and
some of us are still here.
In this room I took 601,
Introductory Electrical
Engineering from Amar Bose.
Most of you probably know
him from speakers, radios,
and headsets.
He knows electrical engineering.
As Phil said, I
graduated with degrees
in, well he didn't quite
say it this way, 18 and 14.
Mathematics and economics.
And, as Phil also noted, I
had the wonderful opportunity
to work with Bob Solow for
my undergraduate thesis
in economics.
The time then was
in the late 60s.
And I wanted to do
something different.
And that something
turned out to be biology.
So what I would like to do now
is to turn to that biology.
The 2002 Nobel Prize in
physiology or medicine
has been awarded to Sidney
Brenner, John Sulston, and me,
for a set of
interrelated studies
that focus around discoveries
concerning a phenomenon known
as programmed cell death.
Why should anyone care
about dying cells?
What does it mean that
certain deaths are programmed?
First, let me say that it is
not notable that cells die.
This has been known for
many years by biologists.
In fact, the real
problem has been
that in order to study cells
one has to keep them alive.
When they die that's not
interesting, that's a problem.
What is notable is that, in
many cases, when cells die,
the cell death is
a manifestation
of a normal process.
More specifically,
what's happening
is that cells die
not because they've
been damaged beyond life, or
in some terrible environment,
but rather because they have
activated an endogenous program
of cellular suicide.
Now what about the term
programmed cell death?
To me, programmed cell death
is synonymous with naturally
occurring cell death.
And let me explain
what I mean by that.
During the development of an
animal from a single cell,
from a fertilized egg,
many things happen.
First, the egg divides.
Over and over and
over again, generating
a large number of cells.
For example, in us, we
don't know exactly what
that number is, but it's
probably on the order of 10
to the 13th.
10 million million.
And then each of these
cells must differentiate.
They must take on
specific characteristics
and become certain
types of cells,
like a nerve cell, or a
muscle cell, or a skin cell.
And then all of these
cells must interact
as groups to form proper
structures, an arm, or a liver,
or whatever, and
proper interactions,
proper interconnections,
as in the most complicated
of organs, the brain.
These processes of cell
division, cell differentiation,
and morphogenesis constitute
basic events of development,
and they define basic problems
in developmental biology.
But now, in addition
to these processes,
there's another process
that appears to be universal
among developing animals.
And that is the
process of cell death.
Quite remarkably,
many of the cells
that are generated
as animals develop
do not survive, but instead die.
And it's this naturally
occurring cell death
that is often referred
to as programmed cell
death, because it is an
aspect of the natural quote
"program" of development.
Now, as biologists have learned
more about programmed cell
death, the term
has been extended
to other deaths that use
the same mechanisms as those
that occur normally
during development.
So, certain cell deaths that
biologists study in vitro,
In the test tube
or on Petri plates,
are programmed cell deaths.
And in some diseases
what one sees
are programmed cell deaths.
Now, that cell death occurs
during the normal course
of animal development has
been known for many years
by developmental biologists.
For example, the regression
of the tail of a tadpole,
as a tadpole becomes a frog,
involves the programed deaths
of essentially all of the cell
types in the tadpole tail.
Similarly, the
formation of digits,
for us fingers and
toes, that formation
involves the elimination
of interdigital regions
that are cellular,
in us, in utero.
And these regions are removed
by programmed cell death.
We can see this
exemplified in birds.
If you think about birds,
think about bird feet,
some are webbed,
and some are not.
And here we see some
friends, MIT friends.
This is from the food
court, this pigeon.
There near all the
trucks, near building 68.
This is Charles River Goose.
Webbed, not webbed.
Programmed cell death,
no programmed cell death,
in the foot.
Programmed cell death
is not a minor event.
For example, approximately
95% of the thymus sites,
blood cells, in our immune
system, 95% that are generated
die by programmed cell death.
In areas of the developing
mammalian brain, as many as 85%
of the nerve cells die
by programmed cell death.
Yet, despite this very
pervasive phenomenon,
it was ignored for many
years by biologists.
Why is that?
Well, I think there are
a number of reasons.
One, I already alluded to.
But another has to do with
timing, with kinetics.
And that is, that this process
of cell death is quite rapid.
So if one takes a snapshot, by
looking at a sample of tissue,
and says, how many cells
are in the throes of death?
The answer is very few.
It's only if you look over time.
And that's something that one
must know to look for in order
to assess it.
To me, perhaps the most
interesting and fundamental
aspect of programmed
cell death is simply
what I've said already.
And that is that there is
a biology of cell death.
And I think the major finding
in the field of cell death
is the fact that cell death is
a normal biological process,
and it is an active process
on the part of cells that die.
The key studies that
led to this conclusion
demonstrated that
specific genes must
function for programmed
cell death to occur.
And many of these studies were
performed in my laboratory
here at MIT.
And these studies
indicated that there
is a biology of cell
death, every bit as much
as there is a biology of other
basic cellular processes,
like cell division,
cell migration, cell
differentiation.
OK, so now, I've been
talking about the biology
of cell death.
And if you think about it,
any biology can go wrong.
And if it does so, in us,
that can lead to disease.
And programmed cell death
is no exception to that.
It appears that some, and maybe
a very substantial number,
of human diseases
are consequences
of disruptions in the control
of programmed cell death.
For example, the major
clinical features
of many neurologic disorders,
the neurodegenerative diseases
include Alzheimer's,
Huntington's, Parkinson's, ALS,
other disorders, stroke,
traumatic brain injury.
In all of these cases, there are
cells that die that shouldn't.
For example, in Lou
Gehrig's disease,
ALS, amyotrophic lateral
sclerosis, specific nerve cell
types, the so-called
motor neurons,
the cells that drive the
contractions, contractions
of our muscles.
They die in the
brain spinal cord,
leading to paralysis,
and eventually to death.
What causes these
cells to die in ALS
and other types of
nerve cells to die
and other
neurodegenerative diseases?
Let me say, very
specifically, we don't know.
But, one hypothesis
is that at least some
of the cell deaths
in these disorders
are ectopic
programmed cell death.
In other words, the cells die
by using that same mechanism
that's used developmentally.
There is a range of
data that support this
to varying degrees in
these various disorders,
and in at least one
neurodegenerative disorder,
retinal degeneration, I would
say the data are very strong.
And if you ask me
to guess, I would
guess that this process
is involved in others
of these disorders as well.
So these are disorders in which
there are too much cell death.
But there also are disorders
of the opposite sort,
in which there is too little
programmed cell death.
So that, for example,
cancer, we generally
think about cancer as a loss
of control over cell division.
So too many cells are generated.
And that's a very appropriate
way to think about cancer,
but it's not the only source
of cancer, ultimately.
If you think about the number
of cells in our tissues,
it turns out that
this number is defined
by two opposing processes,
the process of cell division,
which adds cells, and the
process of programmed cell
death, which takes them away.
That number can
increase, either because
of too much cell
division, or because
of too little cell death.
And certain cancers, the one
studied in the most detail
is follicular lymphoma,
in fact are cancers
that ultimately are
caused because there
is too little cell death.
So what I noted
earlier is that one
of the major reasons for
concluding that cell death is
an active biological process
is the finding that there
are specific genes involved.
And what I'm going to
do now is to tell you
about such genes,
based upon the work
that we've done here
in our laboratory.
And we've discovered such genes
not by studying cell deaths
in humans, or human disease.
Humans are complicated,
and not ideal
experimental organisms
for many purposes.
But rather what we studied
is a microscopic roundworm,
or nematode, caenorhabditis
elegans, or c. elegans
Now, if you ask about
this year's Nobel Prize,
the major player is
this little worm,
c. elegans Because,
all three of us,
Sydney Brenner, John
Sulston, and myself,
are being honored because of
studies of this little worm.
This is Sydney, often referred
to as the father of the worm.
Sydney is a brilliant scientist.
Sydney helped pioneer the
field of molecular genetics.
He had a major role
in the elucidation
of the genetic code, he was a
discoverer of messenger RNA,
and he has countless
other major discoveries.
Sydney was drawn to
c. elegans in part,
because it's very simple.
We now know that there are only
959 cells in the c. elegans
adult. And this can contrast
with the 10th to the 13th
and in humans, or something
in the hundreds of thousands
to millions in insects.
959.
He was also drawn to c.
elegans because of features
of its genetics, features that
made it exceptionally well
suited for genetic studies.
Geneticists are concerned
with rare individuals, events
that occur one in a million.
And so, it's nice
to be able to study
a million individuals, or
10 million, or 100 million,
or what have you.
And with some organisms,
that's very hard.
With c. elegans, because it's
only one millimeter in length,
and very easy to grow,
on a single Petri dish
we can grow 10,000
individuals, and many more
than that in a liquid culture.
So the cellular simplicity
and appropriateness
for genetic studies.
The other thing I should
note is that c. elegans
grows very rapidly.
So geneticists are also
interested in generations.
You go from one generation,
to the next, to the next.
C. elegans has a three
day generation time.
From the time an egg
is produced to the time
that egg is adult producing
its own eggs is three days.
Many generations,
lots of animals,
simple cellular anatomy,
Sydney said worms are good.
Let's use them for
studies, genetic studies,
of developmental biology
and neurobiology.
And he pioneered such analyses.
John Sulston, the third
of this year's recipients,
and I both worked in Sydney's
lab at the Medical Research
Council Laboratory in
England, of molecular biology.
Cambridge, England.
Early 1970s, early to mid 1970s.
I was a post-doctoral fellow.
I was supported by the
Muscular Dystrophy Association,
and as Phil noted, I
came from the Harvard
lab of Jim Watson, Wally
Gilbert, and also Claus Weber.
And there, I had studied
the bacteria phage T4,
and what it does to its
host RNA polymerase.
An interest that
Phil has continued
with in a broader sense.
John was a staff
scientist at the MRC.
He had received his PhD
in organic chemistry
from the University of Cambridge
and then went to La Jolla
and worked with Leslie Orgel on
essentially biochemical studies
of the origin of life.
And came back to
work with Sydney
to focus on the
neurochemistry of c. elegans.
So all three of us were
interested in the worm,
and in fact all three of us
were really very much interested
and maintain a strong interest
in the nervous system.
This is the worm.
The worm comes in two sexes.
The lower one is a male,
the top one is not.
It is a hermaphrodite.
It's essentially a
female whose gonad,
for a brief period of time,
forgets and makes sperm.
That has various
experimental advantages,
but I won't go into
that right now.
This image shows photographs
taken by John Sulston
and diagrams that I drew.
When I arrived in Cambridge,
that Cambridge, John had just
discovered that by
observing living c. elegans,
using a Nomarski optics
under the light microscope,
he could see individual
cells, and follow them
as they divided.
And here's an image from
a paper John and I did.
If you look at either of
these cells, p9 nine and p10,
here's a time
course, each of them
undergoes the process
of mitosis, dividing
to make two daughter cells.
Watching life.
Well, this was pretty amazing.
You could follow
these cells, and then
follow what their descendants
did, and they would go on
and divide.
And so you could follow a
cell, and its daughters,
and its daughters, and
so on and so forth.
And for example, these
two cells, P9 and P10,
they went on and
divided as shown here,
to generate ultimately
six descendants each,
in a very short order of time.
So in talking about
it, John and I
decided that it should
be possible to determine
every cell division
that occurred,
at least during larval
development after hatching,
in this animal.
And with the added efforts
of Judith Kimball, who
was a graduate student with
David Hirsch in Boulder,
and she was interested
in gonadal development,
we did exactly that.
John and I published
the complete description
of the non-gonadal post
embryonic cell lineages
of c. elegans in 1977.
And two years later, Judith
Kimball and David Hirsch
published the gonadal
lineages, thereby
bringing the post embryonic
lineage to completion.
John then closed the loop.
He studied the egg, and followed
that first fertilized cell,
fertilized egg cell, as
it divided and divided,
ultimately to make the larva.
Now this was hard.
Let me just tell
you that this is,
if you picture a bowl of
grapes with about 550 grapes,
and your assignment
is to watch all 550
as somebody is standing there
shaking the bowl, that's
essentially what John did.
So my part was easy.
John did the hard part,
and he did it completely.
And that led to this,
which is the complete cell
lineage of the c.
elegans hermaphrodite.
We also have the male, looks
a little bit different.
Starting with a single
self-fertilized egg,
divides to make two, divides
again, so on and so forth,
y-axis is y.
And that's the developmental
origin of all 959 nuclei
that are found in the adult.
This pattern, and the
corresponding pattern
of the fates of these
cells, is essentially
invariant from animal to animal.
There is enormous biologic
information in the cell
lineage, but I won't
go into that today,
except to say that the
knowledge of the cell lineage
has made possible the
analysis of the mechanisms
responsible for the
development of this animal
at the level of resolution
of single cells.
Now, in addition
to the 959 cells
that are found in the
adult, this cell lineage
generates another 131 cells, not
found in the adult. The reason?
They undergo
programmed cell death.
These cell deaths occur
at different points
in the lineage.
Here we look at the
development of the feeding
organ, the pharynx,
and basically you
find that the cell deaths
occur at different times,
different points in the lineage,
and with nearest relatives
varying quite substantially
over the sister cells.
When you look at these
deaths, what you see,
again using no Nomarski
optics, is most obvious here,
this flat disk
like appearance is
a cell in the throes of death,
and later that cell goes away,
no sign of it can be seen.
Looking at the deaths with
an electron microscope,
they have specific ultra
structural features, most
obvious here is the electron
density of this dying cell.
There are other
features as well,
which told us that these deaths
looked like a process that
had been defined in
pathological specimens
from human patients of
cells that were dying
and were called, the process
was called apoptosis.
So programmed cell
death in c. elegans
is similar to mammalian
apoptosis, which I should add
is pronounced in any
of a variety of ways.
So what we decided, then,
was that since cells
die in a specific
morphological, through
a specific morphological set
of events, at different times,
in different places
in the lineage,
that we could think about
programmed cell death as a cell
fate.
No different from
any other fate,
like differentiating into a gut
cell, or a serotonergic nerve
cell, or whatever
it happens to be.
And if that's true,
then we postulated
there ought to be genes that
control that fate, that control
the decision should
cells live or die,
and that having made
the decision to die,
should carry out that
process of death.
And so what we did was
look for, identify,
and characterize such genes.
And those studies
led to the definition
of a genetic pathway,
as outlined here.
This pathway consists of
essentially four sequential
steps.
The first step is
a decision step.
Every cell in the body
has to decide, I will live
or I will die by killing myself.
The second step is the
killing step itself.
That's what
generates the corpse.
The third step, basically,
is getting rid of the body.
It's a process of engulfment
whereby the dead cell
is removed from the animal.
And the fourth step is
eliminating the debris
of that cellular corpse.
Let me briefly tell
you about these steps.
Some years ago Hilary
Ellis, shown here,
and Chan Desai, shown here,
both as graduate students
in the lab, identified two genes
with functions needed for cells
to die by programmed cell death.
These genes are called CED-3
CED for cell death, abnormal.
CED-3 and CED-4.
And if either of these
genes is inactivated,
essentially all of the cells
that should die instead live.
And it was this finding that
said that programmed cell death
is an active, biologic process.
Then Junying Yuan, as
a graduate student,
performed so-called
genetic mosaic analyzes,
asking the question in what
cells must these genes act
in order for death to occur?
And the answer was in those
cells that are going to die.
Conclusion,
programmed cell death
is, at least to this extent,
a process of cellular suicide.
Junying and another graduate
student, Shai Shaham,
then worked together to clone
and molecularly characterize
these genes.
And what they found is that
first these two killer genes,
CED-3 and CED-4,
first CED-3, looks
similar to a human protein
known as ICE, interleukin 1 beta
converting enzyme, a protein
that had been purified
by two pharmaceutical
companies interested
in human inflammatory disease.
And this information told
us something about CED-3,
because they had
shown that ICE acted
as a protease, an enzyme
that cleaves other proteins,
suggesting to us that CED-3
kills by acting as a protease.
And [? Ding Sho ?] in
the lab confirmed that.
And also suggesting, that since
there was a human counterpart,
that ICE or other
CED-3 ICE-like proteins
may well play a comparable
role in the process
of programmed cell death
apoptosis in humans.
And there has now been much
evidence supporting that.
The second gene, CED-4, also
has a human counterpart,
identified through biochemical
studies done by [? Shel Don ?]
[? Wong ?] in Dallas, Texas.
Biochemical studies in which
he was assaying in a test
tube the process of
programmed cell death,
and found an activity that
activated this process.
And it turned out
to look like CED-4,
which we had already described.
The third c. elegans
gene that plays
a key role in this core killing
part of programmed cell death
is known as CED-9.
And CED-9 is different.
Because whereas CED-3
and CED-4 are killers,
CED-9 is a protector.
It keeps cells alive.
CED-9 was discovered by
graduate student Ron Ellis,
and characterized molecularly
by graduate student Michael
Hengartner.
And what Michael found
was that CED-9 also
looked like a human protein,
this one that had been isolated
because of its involvement
in cancer, a protein known
as BCL-2, were BCL stands
for b-cell lymphoma.
BCL-2 is proto-oncogene,
causally responsible
for follicular lymphoma.
It's what I referred to earlier.
OK, so we have CED-9,
CED-4, and CED-3.
And Shai Shaham analyzed through
genetics the interactions
amongst these genes, and
defined the core genetic pathway
for programmed cell death,
as shown here, where it CED-3
kills, CED-4 kills by
causing CED-3 to kill,
and CED-9 protects,
by preventing CED-4
from killing, causing
CED-3 to kill.
Given the mammalian
counterparts,
we postulated a
pathway as shown here.
With BCL-2, the Apaf-1
CED-4-like factor,
and these proteases, that
are today known as caspases.
So this is the key core pathway.
What else?
Barbara Conrad, a
post-doc in the lab,
analyzed another gene, egl-1
a gene that we had actually
studied and discovered in the
course of studies of behavior.
But it turned out the
behavioral abnormality
was reflecting abnormalities
in programmed cell death.
And what Barbara
discovered was that egl-1
just like CED-3 and
CED-4 is a killer.
We won't go through data but
you can see egl-1, like CED-3
and CED-4 here.
And the genetic
studies she did showed
that although it was a killer,
it was different from CED-3
and CED-4, because
instead of acting,
were CED-3 and CED-4 act
downstream of the protector
CED-9, it acts
upstream of CED-9.
She cloned and characterized
this gene and, whoops.
First pathway.
Pathway, egl-1 upstream.
So egl-1 kills by preventing
CED-9 from preventing CED-4
from activating CED-3.
Right?
Pathway.
What is it?
Barbara cloned it.
And it turned out to
encode a gene related
to BCL-2, the Proto-oncogene.
And it turns out that there is
a family of these BCL-2-like
genes in us.
And egl-1 looks like
another one of these.
Some of these genes,
like the BCL-2
protect against cell death.
Others, like egl-1,
cause cell death.
So egl-1 is upstream, now,
of CED-9 in this pathway.
And it was known at that
point that BCL-2 members
could physically
interact with each other.
So Barbara asked the question
what about CED-9 and egl-1,
and she found that they
interact physically.
And Furthermore,
in studies we did,
and that were also done in
many other laboratories,
it became clear that
said CED-9 and CED-4 also
interact physically, leading
us now to a molecular pathway,
as indicated here,
where we say egl-1
is a direct negative
regulator of CED-9.
So egl-1 prevents CED-9 nine
from acting by physically
interacting with it.
And then CED-9 prevents CED-4
from acting by physically
interacting with it.
And that's what the genetic
and molecular studies indicate.
What is it well one does?
We think the answer to that
is it changes the location
in the cell of CED-4.
And the way in which
we discovered that
was through a series of
experiments done in part
by Barbara Conrad,
whom I've already
shown you a picture of,
and also by Brad Hirsch,
the graduate student
in the lab, Zheng
Zhou, a post-doc in the
lab, and Fangli Chen, who
was an undergraduate
student in the lab.
And what they did
was to use antibodies
against these various proteins
involved in cell death,
and ask the question,
where are the proteins?
And what they found
first was that CED-9
is localized to mitochondria.
OK, what we're looking at here
is a developing c. elegans
embryo.
This panel shows where
mitochondria are.
And basically, CED-9
and mitochondria
are in the same location.
So CED-9 is in mitochondria.
They further showed that
CED-4 is also in mitochondria.
And remember, I've
told you CED-9
and CED-4 physically interact.
So the question,
then, was is either
required for the localization
to mitochondria of the other?
And that we could
ask very simply,
because we had mutants that were
lacking, either CED-4 CED-9.
So in the absence of CED-9,
was CED-4 still mitochondrial?
In the absence of CED-4, was
CED-9 nine still mitochondrial?
Again, without going
through details,
the answer was,
CED-4 localization
depends upon CED-9.
And in the absence of CED-9,
you see a very different
localization pattern.
Here is CED-4 normally,
here is CED-4 without CED-9.
And where it is, is
instead of mitochondria,
it's located around the
nucleus, in a perinuclear way.
A series of studies
that went from here
led us to the model
that's shown here.
And that is that this egl-1
protein, this killer protein,
what it does, is it interacts
with CED-9 on the mitochondria,
displacing, or at least
causing the release of CED-4,
and the translocation
of CED-4 to the nucleus,
allowing CED-4 to be active,
and thereby activate CED-3
and cause programmed cell death.
OK?
So that's the basic model.
That is our core pathway
for programmed cell death.
What I want to do now,
is to turn quickly
to the next step
in this pathway,
the step of engulfment.
When a cell dies by
programmed cell death,
it is swallowed and
destroyed by another cell.
We have analyzed that
process in much the same way
as we've analyzed
the killing process.
I won't tell you how we got
there, but here's where we got.
There are two
parallel and partially
redundant pathways that lead to
the engulfment of cell corpses.
There are three genes that act
in the order CED-716 in one
pathway, and four genes
that have been identified
that act in the order
2, 5, 12 together,
and 10 in the second pathway.
These two pathways
appear to be involved
in the communication between
the dying cell and the cell that
is swallowing it.
Signal transduction pathways.
In one case, what we
believe is going on
is that the dying
cell uses CED-7,
which encodes of protein
of a family known
as ABC transporters, to
basically put on its surface
a signal that says
come and get me.
The engulfing cell
has a receptor
that recognizes that
signal, and then transmits
that signal via another
protein and a whole pathway,
which has yet to be determined.
And parallel to this
process, there's
another process of
intercellular communication.
Again, much of it
is not yet known.
We think the corpse talks
to the engulfing cell,
and signals, now via
a protein complex,
that is responsible for
activating a protein that
is known to be involved in
cytoskeletal re-organization.
That means changes
in cell shape.
When one cell swallows
another, it changes its shape,
and this is how we
think it does it.
OK, now I'm not going to
talk about the work that
led to this model, or the
details of this model,
but rather use it to
introduce another question.
So I've been talking
about programmed cell
death as cellular suicide.
But we've been suspicious for
some time about this process
of engulfment.
If you think about it,
if you were on the scene
and you watched something die,
and as that death was occurring
somebody else was right there
surrounding that individual,
you might be suspicious.
Now, in fact programmed
cell deaths in c. elegans,
the engulfment
process starts even
before the cell division that
generates the cell that's
going to die is completed.
So we had been
suspicious for some time
that maybe cell death
isn't entirely suicide.
Maybe there's a
component of murder.
But we couldn't get enough
evidence to convict.
Peter Reddien, a graduate
student in the lab,
obtained the evidence.
So he started with the
background knowledge that
is a mutant defective
and engulfment,
programmed cell
death still occurs.
So the first order
statement is OK,
engulfment's not needed
for programmed cell death.
But Peter said no, I want
to go a little further.
I want to really address
this in a more rigorous way.
And what he did, was
he took advantage
of an assay that had
been developed in the lab
by postdoc Scott Cameron.
And this was an
assay that allowed
us to look very
easily for cells that
should die, but instead live.
And if you think about
it, that's not always
the easiest thing to do.
Because you've got an
animal with an awful lot,
959 doesn't sound like
a lot, but if you're
going to look for
one extra, you better
know how to do that
in a very precise way.
And Scott developed
a way to do this.
What he did was, he took
advantage of a gene called
lin-11, characterized
by Gwen Actin when
she was a graduate student in
the lab, and which she showed
was expressed in a set of cells
derived from those p cells.
Remember, I showed you those
p cell divisions and p cell
lineage right in the beginning?
Well there aren't
just two of them,
there are actually
more than that.
There are 12 p cells
and a friend called w.
And these cells all divide
to generate six descendants,
except for w, which
does only five.
And the corresponding
descendants
of each of these lineages
differentiate in the same way,
in general, most of
them becoming nerve
cells for particular types.
But, there's a difference.
Six of these cells derive
from p-3 through 8,
survive to become motor
neurons known as vc neurons.
But their counterparts from
the other cell lineages
in the front and
back of the animal
undergo programmed cell death.
Now, if we block programmed
cell death, for example,
with a mutation in
the CED-3 killer gene,
then all of these
cells survive, and they
take on the characteristics
of these nerve cells.
So, we then could
use a reporter,
expressed in these nerve
cells, and basically
use a reporter
that's fluorescent,
that uses the green fluorescent
protein, characterized by Marty
Chalfie at Columbia University.
And ask if we ever
see fluorescent cells
in the front or back of the
animal, where normally there
would be none, in a mutant
defective in engulfment.
And I wouldn't tell you this
if the answer weren't yes.
So here we see a
wild type animal.
And you see green spots.
You also see expression
in another cell type here.
And a CED-3 mutant, no cell
death, lots of green spots.
And here's a CED-7 mutant,
defective in that signal
on the corpse.
Says come and get me.
And what do you see?
You see a cell up here,
where in the normal animal
there is never one.
So you block engulfment,
and you get some survival.
Peter quantified it,
showed it was real,
and showed that it was true for
all of the engulfment genes,
leading to the conclusion
that the engulfment process is
necessary for total
cell death to occur.
Now Peter also used
no Nomarski optics
to watch this process
in living worms.
And what he found was
something quite striking.
So here is a cartoon version
of what I showed you already
as a photograph,
series of photographs,
process of programmed
cell death.
In a CED-3 mutant this
doesn't occur at all.
In a mutant defective in
engulfment what happens is
this process begins.
There's no engulfing cell
that's active and swallowing it.
The process begins, but
then it can regress.
And in fact, it can be episodic.
So that a cell starts to die,
comes back, looks normal,
starts to die again,
comes back, looks normal.
Back and forth,
and generally dies.
But occasionally doesn't.
In the absence of
engulfment, it looks
like cells are kind of
poised on a knife edge,
biased towards death,
usually die, but not always.
Now I think this has
implications for biology,
and also possibly for therapy.
Implicit in what
I've told you already
about the involvement of
programmed cell death,
in a variety of
diseases, is the fact
that these genes define
potential targets
for intervention.
If you block the process of
cell death, in some disorders
that would be good.
If you cause the process of
cell death, in some disorders
that would be good too.
Now, obviously we
have to be careful.
And as with all biology, genes
and targets aren't enough.
To know either the biology
or the therapeutics,
you have to really do
the biological studies.
But there are ways
of pursuing that.
And that, in fact,
is being done.
From these studies I
want to add the comment
that maybe the engulfment
process involves
another biologic phenomena
and another set of targets.
Because in many of
these disorders,
it's likely that
in fact cells are
poised on such a knife edge.
And maybe we can push
them one way or the other.
OK, now, having
said that, I'd like
to finish basically by telling
you a little bit of some
of the newest.
And that is that Peter used
this assay that I just told you
about here, oh and I should
say, this was the conclusion,
engulfment is responsible.
He used this assay, now
very sensitive assay,
looking for extra
green fluorescent spots
to try to find new
genes that might have
a partial role, like
the in engulfment genes,
in the cell killing process.
And what he found,
again, by using
this green fluorescent
protein assay, and looking
for mutations that would tweak
the number of living or dying
cells, what he
found, for example,
in a so-called enhancer
screen, looking
to make the effects of a week
CED-3 mutations stronger,
making a partial killer
into a stronger killer,
he found mutations,
which we call n3376 3380,
the 3376th and 80th mutation
characterized in the lab.
If these two mutations
define two genes involved
in the killing process
that we didn't know
were involved in
the killing process.
The first of them
encodes a novel protein
that has a motif that is
suggestive of interactions
with other macromolecules, and
as I'll tell you in a moment,
we think it's actually
interaction with DNA.
The gene is called mcd-1,
for modifier of cell death.
And the second gene, much to
our surprise, was an old friend.
The second gene,
the second mutation,
turned out to be an allele of
a gene that we called dpl-1.
From studies we had
done in what I thought
was a totally unrelated project
of an oncogene pathway involved
in cell signaling in
c. elegans development.
Oncogene, the RAS oncogene.
An oncogene discovered here by
Bob Weinberg some years ago.
Now, dp proteins are
known in mammals,
they affect cell
proliferation, and they also
affect cell survival,
and cell death.
But nobody knows how.
They act by interacting with
other proteins, like e2-f.
And they interact with Rb
proteins, retinoblastoma,
another gene that's been
characterized by Bob Weinberg
and by Tyler
Jacques here at MIT.
So, we had already analyzed
the roles of dp protein,
and e2-f protein, and
an Rb protein in the c.
elegans RAS pathway.
We had all the reagents.
And Peter said, well,
are they also involved
in this process of cell death?
And again, don't worry
about the details,
just worry about the title.
The answer is yes, dp,
e-2f, and Rb in the worm
are all involved in
programmed cell death.
What they do, we don't know.
But given what we
do know about what
they do in other contexts,
what we postulate
is they act by
controlling transcription,
RNA synthesis, gene expression.
We know that they act downstream
of the protector gene CED-9.
And we have two
basic hypotheses:
either that they are regulating
the expression of the killer
gene CED-3 and/or CED-4,
or that they interface
in this pathway in
a different way,
possibly with genes involved
in the cell cycle, something we
know that these genes can do.
And that's something that
we are currently exploring.
Now, the last step in this
pathway, you'll recall,
is that of degrading
the cellular corpse.
And there's one gene in this
step that was identified
many years ago by John Sulston.
It's a gene he called
nuc-1, possibly a bad name,
because he showed that it
controlled the nuclease.
And what happens is
that this nuclease
is involved in degrading
the DNA in cell corpses.
And if it's not active,
the DNA remains.
But other aspects
of the death process
occur, and one is left with
these little kinetic nuclei,
as shown here.
And that's how John
found this nuc.
He showed that it controlled
the activity of a nuclease,
but it wasn't clear whether this
control was direct or indirect.
And it also wasn't obviously at
all clear what kind of nuclease
it might be.
And if you read the
cell death literature,
there are a large number
of nucleases, each of which
has been implicated in the
process of programmed cell
death.
In one study or another.
So Gillian Stanfield
was a graduate student
in the lab, cloned and
molecularly characterized
nuc-1, and found
that indeed it does
directly encode a nuclease, and
a nuclease of the sort DNase-2.
Which made some people very
happy, and other people
very disappointed.
But, we could add, this
wasn't all there was to it,
and studies that Julian did with
graduate student Yi-Chun Wu,
she showed that in fact there
are at least three nucleases
involved in this process, two
of which are not identified.
The field is very happy.
OK, so we take all
of this together,
and we end up with today's
molecular genetic pathway
for programmed cell death.
Again, we have the four
general steps that I described.
I've told you about
molecular, genetic,
and developmental studies for
some, but certainly not all,
of these players.
But what I will say is
that essentially all
of these players have
human counterparts.
And insofar as
they've been analyzed,
they seem to be involved in
the process of programmed cell
death.
Some of these have
counterparts that are
associated with other diseases.
For example, these two
genes here, ces-1 and ces-2,
cell that specification,
have human counterparts
that are associated with ALL,
acute lymphoblastic leukemia,
another cancer.
And there are other counterparts
through most of this pathway.
So from this, we conclude
that much, and possibly
all of this pathway, is
conserved amongst organisms
as superficially different
as a microscopic worm and us.
Now, I should say that if one
looks at what we know today
about worms, and
what we know today
about human programmed cell
death, mammalian more general,
there are apparent differences.
We don't know yet if
these differences are
real biologic differences, or
if these differences are in part
like the differences of the wise
men who expected the elephant,
and one looked at the trunk,
and one looked at the tail,
and one looked at
the leg, and had
somewhat different impressions.
We know we don't know at all,
we're looking to find out more.
Let me put this, then,
in a broader perspective.
I think, if one looks
at the major findings,
maybe the major
finding, in the field
of molecular genetics over
the last 5 to 10 years,
what we as a field would
say is that what has really
been striking is a
phenomenon that I
like to refer to
as the principle
of biologic universality.
In other words, despite
the diversity of organisms,
we share a lot in common.
Worms and people, and
the fruit fly drosophila,
and a yeast cell that's used
for baking bread or making beer.
There are genes and gene
pathways in all of us
that are strikingly similar.
And we can learn about each
from studies of the other.
And that, I think, maybe
I should say I thought,
was the big news.
Until I saw this.
The cover of Punch
Magazine, from 1882,
where clearly the
artist knew more
than I did, until very recently,
in saying, man is but a worm.
With that the people, members
of my laboratory over the years
who have been involved in the
study of programmed cell death,
current members involved
in that project,
members of the lab involved in
a variety of projects today.
And I actually would like to
ask the members of my lab, past
and present who are here
today, please stand up.
Because it's you who
are being recognized.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Keeping to
an old tradition, when
you give a talk, and
you give new data,
and you express new
ideas, you take questions.
Bob has done that, and Bob
deserves a couple of questions.
We'll take a couple of
questions from the audience.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
was talking about,
but after hearing
him, I was wondering,
how close are you to
practice this in human genes?
HORVITZ: To-- the question
is how close are we
to practice this?
And the question is,
do you mean to use
this information for
treating disease,
or to study this process?
To study this process.
There are many studies
ongoing today in human beings,
in other mammals, that are
drawing upon this information,
and also deriving brand
new information in lots
of exciting ways.
So this is very
actively on-going.
AUDIENCE: My question would
be, what turns those genes on
to start the
process [INAUDIBLE]??
HORVITZ: Right, what
turns those genes on?
OK, that's my next half seminar.
So, the pathway that
I told you about
began with this gene egl-1,
the bcl-2-like killer gene.
And in fact, we've shown
that this gene is regulated
at the level of gene expression,
RNA synthesis, transcription.
We know one of the
transcriptional regulators.
And basically, it causes this
gene to be off in certain cells
that should live, and when
that regulator is not active,
and I can tell you
how that happens,
but it's a longer story,
then this gene is on.
So the specific action of this
one transcriptional regulator
actually makes the decision
for one nerve cell type
whether that cell
should live or die.
For a second nerve
cell type, we have
to transcriptional
regulators, one of which
regulates the other.
And we believe that the second
regulates, again, egl-1.
Although we don't
have data for that,
I think that's the way
the story is emerging.
So the generalization
that we get
from these small
number of studies,
but which we and now
others are also pursuing,
is that a key point
in the regulation
here is at the level
of this gene egl-1,
and that basically
in every cell there
is some combination of
these transcription factors
that decides whether or not
egl-1 will be expressed.
If it's expressed, it makes
the gene, it makes the RNA,
it makes the protein, the
protein interacts with CED-9,
boom, boom, boom, cell dies.
If it's not expressed, that
process doesn't initiate,
cell survives.
I could do the 60 minute
version of that too.
MODERATOR: Is it really a--
last question.
AUDIENCE: Do you
think the absence,
or too much
programmed cell death
is a major contributor
to evolution?
HORVITZ: It is very clear
that some evolutionary change
has occurred by altering
patterns of programmed cell
death.
So that I'll give
you two examples,
quickly, because I had
one up there already.
When you look at
those p cell lineages,
where we got those
green fluorescent cells,
and I told you that
some cells survived
and other cells
died, basically, when
we think about the
evolution of cell lineage,
we think about it
much the same way
as we think about the
evolution of anything.
Genes, segments in a segmented
animal like an insect.
Basically, the way
evolution occurs
is by a process of
duplication and modification.
The same is true
of cell lineage.
You duplicate a cell lineage,
and then you modify it.
And in fact, in that case the
modification involves changes.
Because not all of
the complements,
all of the complement
of that set of six cells
it's generated, are needed in
all of those different places
where that lineage occurs.
Some are needed, some are not.
One of a number of
modifications that
seems to have occurred
evolutionarily,
is a modification of
programmed cell death,
essentially eliminating
one of the cell types
in that region of the animal
where it's not needed.
And I'll leave it with one
example instead of two,
because I can feel Phil
looking at me from here.
MODERATOR: I want to
say one final thing.
Only great institutions
can attract people
like Bob Weinberg.
[LAUGHTER]
HORVITZ: And I would
agree with that.
MODERATOR: People
like Bob Horvitz.
And the students who work with
Bob, and the post-docs who've
worked for Bob, to create
such beautiful science.
Great institutions are
led by great people,
and I want to thank Chuck
Vest for participating
today and being such a strong
supporter of basic science
and the activities of MIT.
So I'd like us to
end by all standing,
and giving a standing ovation
to Bob Horvitz and MIT.
[APPLAUSE]